okay so the mysterious figure in the
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness trailer has been a big talking
point on the internet it's pretty much
become the blue and gold dress of the
comic book community and throughout this
video we're going to be discussing
whether you hear laurel or yanny i'm
just kidding i think we know who it is
after enhanced screenshots have now hit
the web we can see that the figure looks
extremely like leseana lynch aka maria
rambo during the time of filming the
actress was coming hot off the heels of
no time to die and thus her hair would
have also been roughly the length that
we see in the split second shot it was
theorized that this might actually be
tom cruise in a superior iron man suit
but i think when you hold this image
side by side with lynch that they look
pretty much exactly the same now this
has been discussed on twitter all week
with some saying that the facial
features look slightly off and that they
don't line up completely whilst there
are some minor inconsistencies i think
that this is probably down to the one we
see actually being a cgi model when
producing cgi heavy films actors often
get a full body scan so that their
features and frames can be replicated in
a movie they could do this practically
but it would involve tons of wirework
training on lynch's behalf and they'd
also have to get in a team to help
propel her in the air even with all that
we wouldn't get the smooth flying motion
that we see in the trailer and thus i
think that this is simply a cgi model
the features are slightly off because
that's just what tends to happen when a
digital model is used and you only have
to look at older movies to see that's
the case look at the bloody scorpion
king look at him what the hell is this
i'm sure they've gotten better since
then but yeah i still don't think it's
an exact science and this looks way more
like lashawna lynch than it does tom
cruise so no i don't think it's iron man
and i even saw a comment saying that it
might be this and i just
i just can't anymore now i think what's
likely happened in this dimension is
that maria took the flight at project
pegasus instead of carol danvers being
attacked by the cree could have led to
her shooting the tesseract and then
being blasted with its blue light which
the character also has emanating from
her captain marvel also ages at a slower
rate and though she could still end up
being young in a time when mordo is the
same age as he is in the mcu timeline so
i think that sort of settles it i think
the dress is blue you only hear yanny
and we're out here writing the wrongs of
the internet huge shout outs to update
double07 on twitter for posting that
image and i think this massively helped
to clear things up but what about the
rest of the illuminati well that's what
we're going to be breaking down in this
video and if you're enjoying it so far
we'd massively appreciate the thumbs up
also make sure you subscribe for videos
like this every day and with that other
way huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the rest of the video
okay so the biggest part of the trailer
has patrick stewart's voice coming in at
the midpoint
i'm sorry steven
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
we should tell him the truth
because of this professor x was trending
all week and we now know that at least a
variant of him will be featuring in the
film this won't be the one from the fox
timeline as he was killed during logan
but as we know from loki in no way home
you can have similar characters out
there on alternate earths when we see
the shot from strangers back you might
also notice that there are several
members sitting in chairs without being
one absent in the middle this is because
professor x uses a wheelchair and
therefore i think this pretty much
confirms it's xavier but beyond that it
could hint towards him being the leader
of the council now it's likely that he's
part of the illuminati who were
introduced in the comics in the build-up
to civil war made up of professor x iron
man neymar black bolt reed richards
black panther and doctor strange they
controlled worldly events from behind
the scenes operating in the shadows they
tried to steer humanity on a certain
path but over time they ended up going
their separate ways when the group
clashed over several things i think
bringing them into the mcu is a really
smart move and we know at least one
member is professor x but what about the
rest well as we go into the room we can
see a character walking along the top if
we pause the video and then zoom in on
them you can see that this appears to be
mordo in the first trailer you might
remember the shot in which he was
fighting strange and going back to that
it's clearly in this room steven has
handcuffs around his wrist that get
placed under them in this moment and
therefore think that mordo is on the
council what may have happened in this
reality is that defender strange was
killed and this is why they have a
statue to commemorate him this would
also explain the zombie one that
appeared in the tv spot and on the back
of his head we can catch a ponytail we
know that defender strange had one too
and therefore it all kind of ties
together that he's the bad one in his
death the council would have had a need
for a wizard and thus mordo might have
stepped in in order to fill his place we
know from the tar leaks that this
version is called master moto and
therefore he's likely a variant who's
just filling the wizard position in the
group so that's three members down so we
think yeah now we can catch someone with
long hair and though it's been theorized
that this could be a version of thor i
actually think that it's captain carter
the poster that was released alongside
the trailer actually features her shield
in the shattered glass and therefore i
think it's a safe assumption to make
that she will feature in the film at
some point potentially the council is
made up of people that look over the
multiverse and protect it and therefore
she could be the version that we met and
what if she's already had a multiverse
spanning battle and therefore i think
getting her to protect the entire thing
would make a lot of sense now there is
one more figure that remains he who
remains you could say and in total there
are seven chairs but we only have enough
people on screen in the teaser to guess
at five of them that's also going off
the potential that maria rambo is a
member too so there may just be four
figures we can theorize are in the
illuminati now the last one is the most
mysterious of all and after zooming in
all that we can really see is some
emblems on their chest computer enhance
enhance enhanced to the power of 20 so
yeah very difficult to make out
especially as marvel insists on
uploading trailers that were exported on
imovie now there are several
possibilities over who this could be
with the most likely one being reed
richards he was of course a member of
the group in the comics and we know from
the phase four announcement that the
fantastic four are coming john krasinski
is rumored to be playing him and with
marvel delivering on so much fan service
recently it makes sense that they go
with casting that everyone has been
crying out for years next we have
potentially black panther who was also a
member of the team though chadwick
boseman sadly passed away we are dealing
with the multiverse and they might have
brought across michael b jordan's
killmonger to play him like what we had
and what if i am leaning more towards
reed though and we might even get the
version from the fantastic four movie
potentially i don't know were they good
i can't really remember but no is the
answer i'm guessing and moving on we
still have several seats there and
marvel might have even removed those in
them through the use of cgi we know that
the studio has a ponchon for doing this
sort of thing and just in the same way
that andrew and toby weren't in the no
way home trailers this could be
something similar there are rumors that
tom hiddleston will be appearing in the
movie as loki and potentially we might
get a version of him from across the
multiverse who stepped into the shoes of
he who remains i'm not sure how that
would work with the multiverse and
whether there's just one who oversees it
all or with them being broken open that
there's now several that kind of takes
us into the possibility though that it
could be kang or one of his many
variants we know from the end of loki
that there are several of them out there
and for every evil one there could be a
good one to match this would set up kang
to be on the council and in the comics
there was also a council of kangs who
oversaw things in the multiverse either
way there's still a lot of spare seats
and i'd love to hear your theories on
who you think is going to be filling
those chairs we are really at the point
now where marvel can do anything and
they could bring across all characters
from other franchises or introduce new
versions of them in this movie let me
know below and as a thank you you'll be
entered into a competition where we're
giving away three june box sets on the
28th of feb all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now say that to you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch make sure you check out our
breakdown of the insane details in the
trailer which will be linked on screen
right now we found some really cool ones
you might have missed so definitely go
head over there right after this without
the way thank you for singing through
the video i've been poor let's see in
the next one take care peace